hi Michael how are you today this
segment is gonna be so good this is
going to be on the Emmy reel next year
have you been nominated for a Sports
Emmy for about 15 years I was a Susan
Lucci of the New York play-by-play deal
and then I finally won and I gotta be
honest here I think it's one of the most
bogus thing where everybody the industry
celebrates everybody in the industry and
somebody in a cubicle in some small town
in the middle of the country votes on
whether or not you had a good year I
love it
thank you I feel a whole lot better
thank you Mike that's all I wanted to
talk to you about you look in the mirror
you know you're great how do you explain
what's happened here with the Yankees I
you know that it was panic you know
everybody was nervous here in the first
month it seems like the Yankees are
doing okay can you explain that to our
audience well I mean they're getting
much better pitching than people
expected everybody knew they was gonna
get they were going to get run score
because they have a good offense and the
strange thing Dan they've won 16 or 17
games and they really haven't played
great baseball and I'll take last night
for instance they didn't play great
defensively they had a bad sent home of
a runner that should not have been sent
home and they still won the game so
they've got enough to cover up when
they're not playing great and they're
gonna hit better than this could stand
is gonna hit better birds gonna come
back Gardner's not under 200 hitter so
this team is legitimately good now 16
out of 17 good I don't think anybody is
that great but they're gonna be an
awesome team what is it about Giancarlo
Stanton now that maybe he wasn't doing
in the first couple of weeks of the
season I I really think you know I'm
just talking to other players not just
Yankees the cold weather at their
beginning really affects people it
really does and I was talking to an
ex-player who didn't want to be quoted
and said he's da ting now he said he's
not used to da ting and that's gonna
take a while for him to adapt to because
all he's gonna fixate on his hitting as
the da chaffed ur every at-bat and that
doesn't help you going out in the field
actually you know frees your mind so the
warmer weather the fact that the
eighties are winning so the pressure is
off and the fact that he's probably
adjusting to being you know four terms a
pinch hitter if I gave you
Gregorius or anybody else on the Yankees
like who who will get the most MVP votes
out of the group here if I give you the
big CDs yeah go in CDs April would have
made him the MVP
it would have been DD or bets but I
would think it's still going to be
Stanton or judge okay
I mean judges really having a quietly
excellent year he's actually improved as
a player from the 108 52 home runs last
year he has more plate discipline
he just looks great and he's a really
underrated outfielder as well so I think
judging Stan will get the MVP votes do
you look at I saw a comparison with
Mookie Betts in Mike Trout it is that
fair I mean it I don't know if you I
love them both I think Betts is you know
just so much fun and I get to see more
of his games but can you compare those
two I think they're similar skill sets I
think I'd still say that Shawn's better
because he's done it for longer but
Betts is special and he really is and
through 34 games only Fred Lynn had as
many home runs for a Red Sox player 13
so he's doing stuff that hasn't been
done before and he does it in the field
he doesn't on the base pass he's really
he's an outstanding player but I'd still
say trout's probably a smidge better is
the rivalry back between the Red Sox and
Yankees oh yeah
it's bad because they're both
outstanding and they both want to win
the American League East before I think
something that took the the juice out of
the rivalry Dan was that if you won the
wild-card it wasn't that big of a
demerit you know but now it's a demerit
I mean the Yankees last year were down
three nothing before they came to bat
against the twins in the wild-card game
then he'll come back and win that game
they don't go to the seventh game of the
ALCS so it's imperative to win the
American League East so they you've got
that that value now attached to the
American League East title and the Red
Sox are the defenders and the Yankees
want it and the each game is going to
mean a lot and they're both I think the
Yankees Red Sox and the Astros are the
best teams of date and probably in
baseball and I think it's going to be
fun the rest of the year so each one of
the remaining games gonna be awesome
talking to Michael K the Yankees
play-by-play voice joining a Stan
Patrick's show do you have a signature
home run call like you I know you worked
with with John sterling and you just do
SIA but did you ever have that's enough
I came up with something real short and
classy well that's why when I did the
highlights on SportsCenter I would just
go gone because you would time it with
the pitch so let's say Eckersley is
delivering to Kurt Gibson
you know the pitch the swing gone and
then you lay out and then they gets the
first base and then I can you know kind
of fill in some of the stats now I have
the luxury of doing it with the game
already I already know what happens here
but when you do something like SIA like
when you get to the point where you go
that's my signature call well I got this
job 27 years ago and at the time I was
dating a young lady who when she would
get out of the car at the end of the
date sudo City I wouldn't want to be a
I'm gonna hijack that as my home run
call so I I've been doing it since the
very beginning of when I got the job in
1992
wait it's based on love or maybe not
love by the way here is John sterling
with the call on Giancarlo Stanton's
home run last night swung on and lined
on the right left be alive
[Applause]
line drive by Giancarlo
giancarlo
[Applause]
it is I stand Tony and home run and the
Yankees they go what nothing now Mike
does the the TV version of the Yankee
games John sterling goes the radio call
work with John for 10 years Dan yeah and
I I mean I saw him do the first one of
his signatures and I was you know burn
baby burn for Bernie Williams and then
it's become a cottage industry where
like a brand new starter has some signed
balls with all of those calls on it so
he makes a lot of money from it but
really I've told them I don't quite get
I didn't know that oh yeah he's making
loads of money on it now you're not
getting any sia money are you so the
people are hanging out of hotels they
always go could you sign your name they
say put C on it okay I was shocked like
my sister who's like I said she's got a
business spirit she was on was just site
where they they sell things
eBay eBay thank you I like to call ek
but um she said that a Michael K ball
would see on it goes for 79 bucks so she
like all of a sudden was gonna buy like
twelve dozen balls what are you doing
but I'm amazed anybody would pay for
anything I'd give them for free
what's it go for without the CEO on it
about it Oh Michael great to talk to you
and you know what the world is a better
place when the Yankees are playing
better I mean let's just face it it is
but you know what when you said you
struck out twice yesterday yeah I said
you know what Dan could be a major
league cleanup there's no I could be
standing that's right but just stand end
up with more strikeouts than judge you
know I didn't think that would be the
case because he certainly conquered that
yeah but this year he's way ahead of his
pace so I think it's gonna be neck and
neck I I probably say that judge will
probably have a little bit more but it's
gonna be a tough tough race over 300
combined oh yes
I think you'll be pushing for oh my god
oh yeah but Mike this is the problem I
have with the game that there yeah it's
either yeah you know you swing and you
miss or you swing and hit a home run
that there's no movement to the game
itself and I'm not the old guy get off
my lawn it's just I want to see movement
at least when I'm watching instead of
just waiting and you as a play-by-play
boys you know you want you want that
move the runner over or sacrifice bond
or take the extra base or on it like
small things but it's not small to me
because there's movement in the game as
opposed to the pitchers moving and the
hitters moving and that's it I I
couldn't agree with you more I think
there was a stat that 30% of all the
bats last year ended up either with a
strikeout a home run or a walk and
that's just not that great for the game
but I understand that it does lead to
winning and I was doing a game on on
Saturday with David Cone and there was a
no-hitter or double no-hitter through
five innings between the 80s and the
Indians and David said this will be a
record year for no-hitters because
people don't care about striking out and
you're gonna bring in pitchers in the
sixth seventh and eighth inning and all
throw about 100 miles an hour they're
gonna be a lot of no-hitters they really
are and I don't think that's I don't
think that's great for the game I really
don't but how do you fix this I don't
know if you I don't know if you could
fix it unless some smarter GM comes up
with a different way to win games
because right now launch angles and
homeruns and hard throwers and
strikeouts they feel is the best way to
win a game don't put a ball in play and
it can't be booted it's a great listen
by the way I think David Cone is really
good I don't know if the national
audience understands or gets the
opportunity to listen but Kony is every
bit Tony Romo and doesn't get the
fanfare so tell tell David I enjoyed the
listen it's a great listen with you guys
thank you so much because I tell you
what I think that the networks have
really missed the boat on him I think he
could be the best analyst in the game
he's really good Michael thanks for
joining us you got a damn great talking
with you and Michael wouldn't want to be
like okay four more Dan Patrick show to
the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]